hello there I'm John Oliver host of
HBO's last week tonight we have been
banished from television until February
but much like celebrity death hoaxes
will be popping up on the internet
intermittently until then now now you
may remember a little while back we made
a video featuring images generated by
our extremely talented graphics
department which were unfortunately cut
from our show before air things like
this one of Paul Giamatti dressed as a
mango which I'm only really mentioning
now so I can show you that again well
tonight I bring you the lost graphics of
last week tonight part two because
because many of these graphics were
really excellent and we had to cut them
solely for reasons of time for instance
in our episode about chicken farmers we
had to cut this image of a chicken with
a hair cut from the 90s whose name
obviously is hennifer Aniston as well as
this chicken we never we named Heather
Locklear and this one of basketball
great Larry Bird chicken birds chicken
bird those were just three of many we
cut that week some graphics it is clear
why we had to make them because you know
they were never going to exist in real
life like this graphic of a Pope Francis
brand condom which is of course
essentially just a wrapper with a wish
inside but but but other graphics other
graphics we were sort of amazed we had
to make for instance this image of
Jackson Mississippi being overrun by
alligators there's no way that hasn't
happened before how did no one have a
camera similarly this image of Nicolas
Cage agreeing to appear in a movie
called bark to the Future presumably
about a time-traveling puppy or tree if
that exact moment has not happened yet
in life statistically it is about two
and finally some graphics are actually
illustrations of things we came up with
that someone should absolutely manifest
in real life like this one of a Zamboni
ambulance or
Zam Byul ins or this promotional poster
for a real forklift operators of Reagan
Airport an imaginary show with a very
classy tagline go yourself
but I think my favorite loss graphic
might be this one a happy birthday
card which I truly wish were
real because sometimes you know it's
someone's birthday and you want to
acknowledge it but also they're a total
and that's when this card would
come in seriously handy last week
tonight is back in February and until
then I leave you with this picture of
Gallagher about to smash a watermelon
with my face on it up which we had to
cut because it wasn't part of her story
that we were doing it was transcribed
directly from a nightmare I had oh and I
also really leave you with this picture
of a corgi playing a saxophone we're
back on federal Affordable